نتوقف مع هذه الاخبار العاجله عن اصابه
مستوطنين الاذان في هجوم بالدهس في الضفه
الغربيه وفقا لما اورده اخر الانباء هناك
وهذه الصور التي وصلتنا وهي صور اوليه
لمكان الحادث او العمليه حتى الان
عليه ولكن هذه الصور التي وردتنا بشكل
اولي تتحدث عن اصابه مستوطنين اثنين شمالي
الضفه الغربيه طبعا تتزامن هذه الحادثه مع
زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى رام
الله وقبلها الى تل ابيب لتهدئه الوضع بعد
ما حصل
بمخيم جنين ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الحفيظ عبد الحفيظ جوان اهلا بك عبد
الحفيظ من رام الله ما اخر المعلومات
المتوفره حتى الان حول هذه العمليه او
حادثه الدحس
وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه فان سائق شاحنه
فلسطيني متوسطه الحجم قد قام بدحسه اثنين
لا نعرف ان كانوا مستوطنين ام جنديين
واعلى ما يبدو ان احدهم اصيب بجراح خطيره
وتقوم الان مروحيه بنقله للاسعاف وتمكن
المهاجم من الفرار من منطقه حاج الزعتر
وهو جنوب مدينه نابلس وفك مصادر امنيه
تقول انه فر باتجاه الجنوب باتجاه مدينه
رام الله والقرى المحاضيه وعمليات
المداهمه والتفتيش تجريح حتى هذه اللحظه
هذه التفاصيل المتوفره حتى هذا اللحظه عن
هذا الهجوم ههه تبقى معنا عبد الحفيظ
المزيد من هذه الصور التي تفصلنا لمكان
هذه العمليه وكما افادنا قبل قليل اذنا
عبد الحفيظ باصابه المستوطنين في حادثه
الدهس عند زعتره وحادث زعتر تحديدا همم
والمصادر العسكريه كانت تحدثت عن ان حادث
دهس عند هذا الحاجز قد يكون
متعمدا همم كيف يمكن ان نعرف اكثر عن حجم
الاجراءات الامنيه التي اتخذت في هذا
المكان وفي محيطها او في بقيه المناطق على
اثره عبد الحفيظ
ام طاهر هناك اصلا انتشار اسرائيلي كثير
منذ ثلاثه واربعه ايام اعلنت اسرائيل على
النشر ثلاثه كتائب اضافيه في الضفه
الغربيه وبالتالي هناك تجديد كبير على
الحواجز الاسرائيليه وهناك ايضا انتشار
كبير للمستوطنين وتحديدا قرب حاج الزعتر
وعلى حاجز الزعتره يعني عشرات عمليات
الاعتداءات التي نفذها المستوطنون على همم
مركبات الفلسطينيين وبالتالي حتى موضوع
حادثه لا نعرف يعني همم طبيعه هذا هذا
ربما يكون احد الفلسطينيين حاول القرار من
المستوطنين وحدث ذلك بالمناسبه قبل يوم
واحد قبل يومين عند حاجز حواره القريب
عندما يعني اطلقت الجنود الاسرائيليون
النار على سائق فلسطيني ايضا عندما حاول
الفرار من المستوطنين الذين كانوا يلقون
الحجاره على مركبات الفلسطينيين وبالتالي
طبيعه هذا الهجوم حتى الان غير واضحه ايضا
كما تشاهد يعني الجو ضباب ومطر والشوارع
زلقه للغايه وبالتالي
الموضوع ليس عمليه متعمده وان مرضت فعل
همم فلسطيني على التعرض لهم من قبل
المستوطنين
نعم هذا وارد هذا وارد بشكل كبير عشرات
العمليات التي تصنف على انها عمليات دعسه
وعمليات هجوم تكون اساسا حوادث سير وحدثت
قبل ذلك بان يعني اطلقت قوات الاسرائيليه
النار على سائقين مركبات فلسطينيه بسبب
حوادث سير او حاله ارتباك نظرا لتجديدات
العسكريه الكبيره والنظارادي الكبير
للمستوطنين همم ننتظر التفاصيل الاضافيه
حول هذا الحديث لنعرف
ايضا همم مرشح لمثل هذه العمليات في خصوصا
في ظل هذه الايام تقول القوات الاسرائيليه
ان هناك عشرات الانذارات بنيه فلسطينيين
عمليات فرديه من هذا القبيل سواء عمليات
بس او عمليات الطعن
معك عبد الحفي همم في حال ورود اي معلومات
اضافيه حول حادث الدهس الذي ربما مثل ما
ذكرت في اوروبا مالني لا يكون متعمدا شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا مر رام الله عبد الحفيظ جوان